Speaker 1: In many ways, the stock market
is not the economy.
We've talked about that endlessly over the
years.
The stock market tells you one very specific
thing.
It relates to a few other aspects of the economy.
But stocks can do well while things can be
not so good for much of the American people.
Now, that being said, Donald Trump and many
of his followers hung their hats there, maggots
on stock market performance.
And more than that, Donald Trump told us if
Joe Biden wins, the stock market will collapse,
401.
KS would be worth nothing.
We never believed it in advance because the
stock market generally does better during
Democratic presidents than Republican presidents.
But now we know it didn't happen because the
stock market has done better during Joe Biden's
first 100 days than during any president's
first hundred days in the last seventy five
years.
Remember when Trump said this,
Speaker 2: the stock market had to talk about,
if I'm elected, if he's elected, the stock
Speaker 1: market will crash?
Well, it didn't happen.
Going back to World War two, the S&P 500,
the broadest of the major three indices, posted
a better return during Joe Biden's first hundred
days than during any other president dating
back seventy five years.
The S&P 500 is up twenty five percent since
Joe Biden was inaugurated.
It was up under 15 percent under Donald Trump
during the same period.
Previously, the record for the 100 day mark
was 20 percent under John F. Kennedy.
Now, of course, you will hear from those who
don't want to accept this, that this is only
because Joe Biden was handed a perfectly timed
covid recovery.
But that's wrong.
The stock market recovery to pre covid levels
was complete before Trump left office.
That's not what is going on.
You will hear well, it's because of the so-called
money printing that the covid stimulus that
Joe Biden's covid stimulus did know.
That was relatively recent and that has an
impact that takes time to be seen and understood.
And, of course, you will also hear from right
wingers saying, well, things might look good
now, but wait until Joe Biden jacks up the
corporate tax rate and the capital gains rate
and the income tax rate and then things are
going to implode.
Probably not.
Analysts at JPMorgan have looked at the proposal
and have said that it should really be a modest
impact.
So to refresh, the stock market is not the
economy, but when one side says basically
it is and it will crash under Biden and the
opposite happens.
That's very much worth doing a reality check
on, here's more context on that Trump quote
about the stock market from earlier day.
Speaker 2: And Mr. President, I move on to
the next question.
They say the stock market will talk about
if I'm elected, if he's elected, the stock
market will crash.
OK, let me just say very quickly.
Speaker 3: The idea that the stock market
is booming is his only measure of what's happening
where I come from in Scranton and Claymont,
that people don't live off of the stock market.
Just in just the last three or three years
during this crisis, the billionaires in this
country made, according to the Wall Street,
700 billion more dollars, 700 billion more
dollars, because that's his only measure.
What happens to the ordinary people out there?
Speaker 4: What happens to them?
Speaker 1: So the point is Joe Biden has not
been hanging his hat on stock market performance.
That's likely why Joe Biden hasn't been bragging
about it on Twitter.
Trump did hang his hat on stock market performance
and was completely and totally wrong on what
would happen.
And Joe Biden's first 100 day performance
is significantly better, about two thirds
better than Donald Trump.
That's not an error, 25 percent versus 15
percent.
That is 67 percent better under Joe Biden.
So don't fall for it.
Yes, they'll have some talking point to try
to talk their way out of it.
But just follow the data and look at history
as well.
Let me know your thoughts.
Did you ever believe the stock market was
going to crash under Joe Biden?
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Let me know